يصل التحقيق بقضيه التسريبات الى منتهى او
يقترب من الحل على حد وصف الرئيس بايدن
بمشهد درامي تلقي فيه قوات فيدراليه مدججه
بالسلاح القبض على عسكريا يافع في مقتبل
العمر امام منزل عائلته التي عرفت بتاريخ
يمتد لعقود من الخدمه العسكريه
تنتقل كاميرات الصحافه سريعا كما العائله
الى ابواب قاعات المحكمه هناك حيث يمثل
المتهم الشاب جاك تشيره وتنتقل القضيه الى
سؤال جديد ما هي اجراءات المحاكمه وما
الذي قد تفضي اليه
يقضي القانون الامريكي بان يوقع كل شخص
يملك تصريحا امنيا اتفاقيه عدم افشاء
المعلومات وفقد القانون الامريكي فان خرق
هذه الاتفاقيه هو عمل اجرامي وهو ما تم
اعتقال تيشيرا بناء عليه وفقا للمدعي
العام سيتهم تيشيرا بجريمه التجسس
والاحتفاظ بمعلومات سريه ونقلها ومشاركتها
يمكن ان يدان مرتكب هذه الجريمه بعقوبه
تصل الى السجن لعشر سنوات لكن الحكم الذي
قد يواجهه تيشيرا قد يكون اكبر اذ سيعتمد
على عدد التهم التي سيدان بها وما اذا كان
سيتم تقديم هذه التهم على التوالي او
بالتزامن على سبيل المثال اذا اتهمت شيرا
بتسريب معلومات ليس لديه تصريح امني
بالوصول اليها فستكون احددتهم هي الوصول
الى معلومات بغير تصريح كذلك تعتمد التهم
على من شاركت شير المعلومات معهم مشاركه
معلومات سريه مع رعايا اجانب هي تهمه اخرى
قد يواجهها ويدان بها وهي تختلف عن تهمه
تسريب المعلومات لتحقيق مكاسب شخصيه او
توقع خدمه منها في قضيه مشابهه هي قضيه
ويكيليكس الشهيره حكم على الجندي الامريكي
الذي ادين بالتسريب بالسجن 35 عاما لكن
الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما قام بتخفيف
العقوبه لاحقا